every student who's have an admitted
freshman at Hillsdale College we send
them a copy of Aristotle's of ethics
that's a frightening thing to do
everybody knows that Arizona is a little
complicated right
I brought my toy Aristotle here this
morning so you can see how friendly he
is the reason that I wanted to take this
course on the ethics was first of all I
think dr. arns an amazing teacher I
learned so much from him and I knew that
he would describe Aristotle's ethics in
a way that was both profound but
applicable because it's not just that
you're free to choose it's also that
your choices matter very much and they
make you what you are through the ethics
we learn that with time if we really
want this through practice through
trying again and again even when we fail
we can become the people we want to be
the people we know that we can be so
it's not just some random philosophy
book that has these high end might be
things that are never going to apply
it's something that you can do now it is
the greatest self-help book for
understanding you know how to be happy
how to be good in this life fielding
questions from dr. Arnn regarding a book
that he is read at least forty four
times is more than a little bit
intimidating Dominick Whalen over there
just said that he didn't get that part
so I would like to invite him to just
sit here through this class and
contemplate hahaha especially since I've
read it a grand total of once Pete
definitely keeps you on your toes
doesn't let you get away with any
imprecise answers okay that had all the
elements but it was a little sloppy I
think it's really important to read
Nicky McKeon ethics because it actually
is able to lay out in this direct and
systematic way what specifically it
means to be good and how to do it it's a
way to find out what we all really want
to know everybody wants to know how to
be good everybody wants to do the right
thing so this is really the most natural
course the best class that you can take
and I think if you stick with it it gets
more beautiful as you go along the
things it says our eternal it's one of
the greatest books with probably one of
the greatest Aristotle teachers alive
you'll find out that if you live a very
good life pleasures will come to you
beyond imagining but you have to earn it
[Music]
[Music]